BILLION AFTER ALL.
>> 250,000 SOUNDS CONSERVATIVE.
THANK YOU.
>> LET'S GET PERSPECTIVE ON ALL
THE THINGS THE PRESIDENT IS
JUGGLING.
BRET
BRE
BRETT HUME JOINS US.
AFTER THE RIPPLES THAT CAME LAST
WEEK, HE SAID WE'RE NOT BACKING
DOWN.
HE SAID WE UNDERSTAND THE FINAL
AMOUNT AND THE FINAL DECISION IS
YET TO COME.
WHERE DO YOU THINK HE GOES?
>> MY GUESS IS HE'LL GO THROUGH
WITH THE ONES -- THE TARIFFS
THAT HE'S ANNOUNCED.
HE MAY SOFTEN THE EFFECT ON SOME
ALLIES AS PRESIDENT GEORGE W
BUSH DID.
THIS -- I THINK THESE TARIFFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER THEY IN
THEMSELVES WILL CAUSE AS MUCH
HAVOC AS SOME ARE PREDICTING.
I DOUBT THAT.
THE WORRY IS WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT.
WHETHER IN FACT THE RETALIATION
MEETS WITH RETALIATION AGAIN
FROM HIM.
PRETTY SOON WE HAVE A TRADE WAR.
THERE ISN'T ANYBODY I KNOW OF
THAT THINKS A TRADE WAR IS A
GOOD IDEA.
DESPITE THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS
ABOUT TRADE WARS BEING EASY TO
WIN, THEY USUALLY END UP BEING A
LOSER FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED.
MY GUESS IS THE PRESIDENT WILL
PULL BACK AND THIS WILL BE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE PRESIDENT
YOU KNOW BLUSTERING TALK AND
THREATS AND SO ON.
AND -- AND IT ENDS UP BEING LESS
THAN MEETS THE EYE.
WE'LL SEE.
>> HE SAID HE'S NOT SURE THERE
WILL BE A TRADE WAR BASED ON HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE EXPECT
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
MEANWHILE WE HEARD FROM
DEMOCRATS.
I TALKED TO SEVERAL OF THEM LAST
WEEK WHO WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND HAPPY ABOUT THIS IDEA.
MOST OF THEM IN THAT RUST BELT